you know there was the whole Bieber
thing last week I don't want to talk
about the eggs or the drunkenness or the
weed or the arrests or any of that but
this was fascinating on MSNBC Andrea
Mitchell reports Andrea was talking to
former congresswoman Jane Harman about
NSA domestic spying I think this is an
important issue and then suddenly had to
break in and stop her for breaking news
right now in Miami Justin Bieber has
been arrested on a number of charges the
judges reading the charges including
resisting arrest and driving under the
influence he's appearing now before the
judge for his bond hearing let's watch
okay so yeah she was talking about the
NSA domestically spying on our phone
calls but had to be interrupted because
Bieber was being arraigned is this just
the death finally is this the final nail
in the coffin of mainstream media it is
so embarrassingly awful and Andrea
Mitchell who I have no great lover you
can even see she was paying you to even
have to break away so I don't put all
the blame on her because it's producers
and executives and all that but is this
just the death of this thing well I
think cnn.com devoting their front page
to Miley Cyrus twerking was maybe the
first salvo in all this I mean it's it's
terrible but unfortunately I think they
get rewarded for it I think that they
probably get the numbers that they want
to get and so they feel like they have
to do it and you know I remember there
was there was some journalists somewhere
I'm forgetting that we're who basically
wrote a column in which he vowed he
would never write about Paris Hilton
again yeah he goes I'm using I I'm not
gonna be part of the problem here I'm
just gonna I'm stopping you the rest you
can do what you want to do I quit and I
think if any of the major news networks
took a similar we are not gonna inter
interrupt a discussion of NSA domestic
spying to talk about Justin Bieber or
anybody else you know I think that there
would be a at least a segment of
viewership that would say bravo yeah
well to that end I did ban myself from
tweeting about the Kardashians after the
wedding
after after the divorce I was like
that's it and I have not tweeted about
the one so I'm doing my you were all
that broken by that yeah we're going to
what point there's someone who was still
into this because as you said you felt
there was a little bit of pain from
Andrew Mitchell and having to do it the
producers who were in the air said go go
go go go to break to Justin Bieber I'm
sure they're going why are we breaking
of Justin Bieber but they have to
somewhere up the ladder there's someone
who's making decision up that really
thinks this is great
there must be I mean all the way to the
top all the way to the top Carrie saying
god this sucks but I can't do anything
about it somebody can do something about
it
but no one will because someone has
really believes in this where does that
break off happen is what I wonder I
don't think anyone knows and that's why
I think it keeps happening nobody sort
of knows who's in charge and who should
make those decisions but is this sort of
ultimately why cable news was doomed to
failure from the start we've had a run
of it for fifteen years or something but
you know at some point we used to have
the the public airwaves and ABC NBC and
CBS would give you the news and there
were trusted people like Walter Cronkite
but then when it became all about
ratings on cable news that then they had
they feel they have to do this stuff
whether they have to or not but so don't
we need our cable or our airwaves back
well I I think I think Pandora's Box is
open you know I mean then 24-hour cable
is we've just good news if we just have
we've discovered is is the beast that
has to be fed you know and that's why
Nancy Grace has a show you know and
that's why you can devote endless
endless hours on these murder trials
that are not news to the general public
you know and anything that's more drivel
than the minutia of a trial really and
any of these trials when they show them
all day long is that could you think of
anything that we're just waste it
becomes a sort of desperate need to just
fill those hours with something you know
and i think that i think that MSNBC has
been classier than that up until now and
i think that's why so people paying
attention to this if fox had done it i
don't think it would be getting the kind
of blowback that we're experiencing now
because you know they've been very happy
to like do in-depth articles about you
know sexual harassment at Hooters or
whatever if it meant showing you know
b-roll footage of scantily clad women
but I think MSNBC was was you know would
say what you will about their politics
was thought to be a little classier than
us yeah
I'm all for if you want to watch Justin
Bieber in the courtroom
there's tons of channels that's what
those are there for I mean like you said
we you have CNN you have headline news
you have all the ones they go they have
their thing is that Nancy Grace likes to
do these ridiculous murder murder trials
and then also come after every
particular kidnapped child but the those
that have their venues watch Justin
Bieber it should be on a particular
channel so you go arm city the NSA stuff
I know they're doing 24 just be very
make TMZ hit 24 hours or let HLN let's
see in and actually handle the news you
know every time we do a story like this
people say but why are you talking about
Bieber at all or any of that but but on
YouTube the beauty of what we can do is
you don't you just click what you want
to click we're not tricking you into
clicking it or showing it for an hour so
isn't that ultimate sort of validation
for what you do by being part of an
online yeah in that argument about what
you guys are covering it so you're part
of the problem too you know but we're
talking about why it's ridiculous so if
we just sit back and be quiet with the
media angle when I talk about the story
going and by the way we're gonna what a
Justin Bieber save that judge we didn't
bring you that stuff up we don't care
about that but if no one talks about the
problem and it just be quiet about it
we're just allowing it to happen just as
much because obviously you you mean you
can you the person who's complaining
give me submit no well network came true
you know that's an entire movie about
what happens when the news division go
falls under the entertainment division
umbrella and that's what happened you
know and now yeah you're right new shows
have to have ratings new shows have ad
rates and so they and now are under the
falling into the same rubric as whatever
other crap is on TV yeah